just because we grew up with the
Internet we assumed that the internet is
all grown up
I met sherry Turkle in October last year
when we were both invited to speak at
the conference organized by the Hannah
Arendt's Center on the topic of being
human in an inhuman age for a meet of
the first time that I was confronted and
could hear mr. ray couch while and this
is a man who truly believes and of all
kind of evidence that we are getting
close to what he calls the singular man
now the singular man as he explained is
this idea that with the exponential
growth of Technology we are probably
2025 years away from the fusion between
the computer and the human being and
sherry Turkle was standing there not
like Cassandra she was not preaching
doom or gloom in any way the only thing
she said essentially was let's take a
break and let's think is this really
what we want I'm extremely proud and
happy that she's here please join me in
a very warm welcome to Sheraton
there was something I didn't see 15
years ago and thing that I didn't see
was that mobile connectivity all those
little phones that we just silence
you know what tried to remember to
silence when we walked in here that that
kind of mobile connectivity would mean
that we would be able to bail out of
what was going on in the physical real
at any time and that we would want to
and that we would want to we texted
family dinners I study families where
everybody's texting at breakfast where
everybody's texting at dinner I go to
playgrounds where parents are texting if
their kids are trying to get their
attention when they're playing on you
know the swing set or the jungle gym so
technology proposes itself as the
architect of our intimacy's Winston
Churchill says we made our we make our
buildings and
buildings make and shape us it's all
about control
you send out so much and you get so much
back so many in fact that the only way
you can get control is by communicating
with the kind of staccato texts I think
that Shakespeare would have said we are
consumed with that which we are
nourished by and and in that being
consumed by this email as it ramps up
its volume and velocity we confront a
terrible paradox because we say that our
world is increasingly complex and yet as
we ramp up this volume and velocity we
feel that the most important thing is
getting that quick response and so we
start to send out a message to which we
know we can get a quick response so we
ask a simple question to get a simple
answer when I talk to teenagers about
the certainty that their privacy will be
invaded my thoughts go to my very
different experience growing up in
Brooklyn New York in the 1950s and my
grandparents lived in Brooklyn had had
an experience in Europe and come to the
United States to escape that and my
grandmother took me down to the
mailboxes every morning and she said to
me in the United States it's a federal
offense for the government to open up
your mail that's the beauty of this
country from the earliest age my civics
lessons at the mailboxes join together
privacy and civil liberties and I think
of how different things are for children
today who accommodate to the idea that
their email their messages are shareable
and unprotected all these internet gurus
are quick to say that privacy is dead
and that the way to deal is to just be
good young people can make a difference
but are you too distracted to care I
look forward to our conversation thank
you
I wanted to ask you about the Tea Party
you see that people may be hiding in my
view hiding away from the influence of
Internet like hiding back in their cage
I think the Internet has this equality
that you get more and more you know when
you make a Google search yeah and at the
top things that come up in your Google
search are not the most popular things
on Google you know that it's not the
most popular searches on Google it's the
things that Google thinks you want to
see so in the old days you'd get a
newspaper and it was a fairly decent
newspaper you know your eyes could
wander but you'd kind of have to read an
opposing point of view and opposing
editorial news about a country you've
never heard of you know if you're a
Republican you'd have to hear about what
the Democrats were doing if you're a
Democrat you'd have to hear about the
Republicans we're doing you can get now
the newspaper of me and I feel that the
Tea Party is essentially a movement of
people who have put themselves in a
position not just of nostalgia but of
really denying asset and here I added
Oriole eyes a set of realities of the
complexity of the American experience
right now I mean that's what I think
we're facing now the world has become
more and more complex and yet we're in a
communications milieu that facilitates
more and more people seeing the world as
simpler and simpler that's not good I am
a little dork
it almost sounds as if you're describing
some dangerous drug that is so dangerous
because it captures everyone and it's
socially acceptable to use it and it so
takes us all along like I don't know in
the 19th century in China where 40% of
the people was using right well I have
an interesting position I have a very
interesting position on this notion of
Internet addiction because most people
most psychologists the United States use
the metaphor of Internet addiction when
they talk about this and I really those
of you who've read alone together know
that I don't like that metaphor because
if you talk about it as an addiction
there's only one thing you can do which
is get off it and I hope first of all
you don't want to get off it because of
all the bounties that it brings us and
secondly you don't want to get off it
because it is our life partner it is the
technology of our time it is our partner
in the human adventure of our moment and
yet I have to be respectful of the
metaphor because it describes something
neurochemical and I don't want to deny
that something neurochemical is
happening who I'm really mad at who I'm
really mad at and this is such a this is
why when I say let's not be so fast
about oh let's give an iPad to every you
know six-year-old they're so happy with
it'll be so educational who I'm really
mad at is all my colleagues in education
who said things like Oh teachers should
take multitasking lessons from students
because this is the new skill of the
twenty this is the new learning skill of
the 21st century my prediction is at the
school of the future is going to be a
classroom where we learn to uni tasks
again where we learn to concentrate on
one thing at a time in order to do it
better and bite me back to Amsterdam in
a few years and you tell me if I'm not
right my prediction
thank you very much
what struck me most about the book that
sherry Turkle wrote and also about her
lecture just now is the way in which
technology is striking back so to say I
mean there is this vision where we are
the creators of Technology we possess
technology we can decide what to do with
it but there is a point at which
technology is starting to shape how we
think and how we work with it and how
our society has to accommodate the
changes technology brings and that was
for me it's it's kind of taking a
different stance or a different
perspective to look at the whole issue
which can teach you a lot of new things
was the greatest failure for me will you
now change your behavior listen to
sherry Turkle well that's a tough
question I think in a way I was already
quite aware of these issues for instance
on Facebook of course I do have a
Facebook account but I've made it just
about as private as you can I mean
unless I friend someone on Facebook they
can't see anything which I have on my
face literally nothing I mean they can
only see a picture but I'm careful to
choose a picture it doesn't reveal too
much but of course I know that
everything I put on facebook becomes the
property of the company Facebook so I
suppose the only way to deal with that
the only right way to deal with that
would be to just delete my facebook
accounts and personally I'm not ready to
do that yes like I don't know Saint
Augustine said God please change me
please fix my bad habits but just wait a
little while imagine a new government
fascist governments
I'm not saying this will happen but what
if this happens they don't need a Stasi
they don't need there needed a secret
police or an FBI because they have
Facebook they can use your information
know what your political preferences are
and just use it against you so this
frightens you well yeah I think it's
creepy that people are so willing to
give up their own privacy just because
they are afraid to miss out but I think
you know as she says it's not we don't
have to stop using social media but we
can force them to make privacy privacy
settings because this is many of the
things they are doing all right would be
illegal if is happening to to mail or to
other forms of communication like phone
phone calls you you cannot stop phone
calls it's legal but you can take this
off the internet and use it because
there are not yet laws for for these
types of communication on the Internet
I think there are several ways to take
action
I think privacy is a hot-button issue
all over the world I think we are
becoming aware of how much we have lost
how much technology has cost us in terms
of basic privacy and I think that I
think there are a lot of there was a lot
of sentiment in the audience that who
cares
I have nothing tied
who cares what anybody knows I've done
nothing wrong
but I'm optimistic that that that this
hot-button issue of privacy is going to
be where things start I do and I think
it will it will start as a slowly as a
kind of consumer movement I think it
will people will demand more privacy and
their email
their social networks and it will be
very slow but if consumers demanded a
private email an email that offered
privacy if they demanded social networks
that offered a higher level of privacy
they would get them and how would you
like students to demand this well first
of all they vote with your feet when
Facebook for example announces a new
privacy setting that doesn't give you
privacy consumers can object consumers
when when consumers have done that
Facebook has retreated and that should
happen more and more and with greater
and greater ferocity I think that's very
important I think you can demand it in
your work environment understand what
the privacy assumptions are in your work
environment but I think on the social
network is the place to start
all right well final question lots of
people are wondering about this
especially after you master class I own
Facebook yes I am how do I use Facebook
to say I'm gonna write about my master
class and I tell people if I've written
something I post what I've written so
that people can read what I've written
it there's a transcript of something
that I've said or if I radio interview
I've done
they're people on Facebook but I don't
use it as in me as a personal medium
people become your friends there they
are not your actual friends they know I
would say they're my friends are more my
fans
you